top female professions that cheat at the
top of the list we have women that are
the Breadwinners in the household it's
interesting that happens because women
we know like to look up to a giant they
want to look up to a man and be like
this is the best I can do everybody else
is invisible this is what the preference
is in the model for long-term
relationships the second thing she said
was that it was musicians influencers
and also flight attendants see women are
generally better at cheating than men
are because they have more to lose like
there are consequences to promiscuity
and if you travel around as a flight
attendant it's a lot easier to get away
with it also if you're a social media
influencer and a musician you're getting
constant attention and validation from
other guys and if you marry a guy and
your day is essentially getting likes
and attention and comments and
validation eventually guys with some
blue check marks that are verified will
get her attention maybe say something
interesting and nice and they might look
like a better option than you do